why is this hot we lookin so red I
thought that the hot wing is looking
back at me like this hey what's going on
everybody for first we feast I'm Sean
Evans and you're watching hot ones it's
the show with hot questions and even had
her wings and today we closed out season
10 with John boyega
he's an actor and producer you know best
from films like attacked the block
Pacific Rim uprising and Star Wars
speaking of you can catch him in Star
Wars Episode nine the rise of Skywalker
which is set to theaters on December
20th John boyega welcome to the show
thank you for having me
I've heard you rave about pepper soup in
the past so I take it you're no stranger
around so I shouldn't have said that man
this is a mad thing Matt well you know
what we're here and I'm happy to be a
dude
watch the show big fan
mm-hmm that's good yeah this is good
chicken wings man what you don't get
this one my belly's playlist over here
on 34th Street Oh ah-ha see this is good
free plug
[Music]
everything on this table is against me
dude I'll go make sure I'm on point
focus focus focus
I understand that girion food it can get
quite spicy where we at on the Nigerian
heat index probably not even registered
with this this is not registering on my
tongue nothing no there's nothing
and then I understand that you took
Harrison Ford to a Nigerian meal in
London yeah what was that like because
that seems special on multiple levels
yeah on the day we were on the
Millennium Falcon actually due to
shooting a scene and Harrison was like
you know what I want to go and eat like
real food like different kind of food
like different tastes someone sick of
the chicken breast in the salad I saw
like a cool man come down to the ochem
road it's a Nigerian restaurant there
and go there and have some food and we
went down there got a car and he ate
everything he ordered literally more
than me and then in the car back he was
slumped he was gone so gone that he was
just like can we swap positions because
you have a lot more legroom
the Harrison forward then break in like
literally climbed over me to get into my
seat with swap places and he was sleep
like snoring gone Nigerian food calm
yeah and then I know that your major
proponent of the food scene and Peckham
including your favorite chicken shop
over there on ride Lane yeah what can
you tell people about the chicken shop
culture in London because one time I
went to Tottenham with this guy that
chicken connoisseur oh you were gonna
slow down you know chicken kind of
smooth and we were at this spot and
Tottenham and kids were just banging on
the window trying to get in to take a
picture with the guy yeah yeah I mean
you know he's the best of the British
especially when it comes to chicken
wings you know you get your standard two
piece chicken and chips and get you the
number four which is really good they
throw in some ribs and some corn on the
cob so you know who got some good nice
dishes back overnight well it's a
culture like you know it's a nice cheap
as well you know in little box fries
chicken you could for the day
[Music]
Ocampo nothing a compliment
step up guys step up step it up remember
he said this remember he said this know
what is how I'm gonna go out confidence
you've kept some pretty cool keepsakes
from your time at Star Wars from red
spider-man stormtrooper helmet that JJ
gifted you to the Han Solo action figure
that you got signed by Harrison yeah
which one is most special to you when
you think about your time on set that
Harrison Ford figure is really special
to me
like I was able to hold on to that
figure and go through the whole
franchise and get multiple different
people to sign it this is you know new
characters are we have met yet and
obviously you know some some characters
that are you know pivotal to the Star
Wars story but they're not obviously on
set all the time and when I could locate
them I'd locate them and I have to
figure on me and be like could you
please sign better video game in your
opinion the Force Unleashed or
Battlefront
I would say bow front definitely a bad
game because of the online platform and
then the film is one of the most
lockdown secretive films that I can
recall being made yeah can you reveal
some of the behind the scenes security
measures that go into putting a cap on
Star Wars I know I remember I bought an
overcoat because every time we leave the
set we can't actually leave in costume
so if you want to go to the toilet and
understand studio a lot we can't just
leave-- we have to put these these
cloaks on and I put my cloak on and I
couldn't get back in to set security guy
must have been in his first day and he
was just like nah nah nah I can't let
anyone in but I'm not yeah but I'm in
them I'm in the film to promise you a
minute but good enough like one of the
senior security dudes came down and you
know gave me the Parsee let's read that
yeah that's
amid
[Music]
cool so to someone on the outside of the
movie business it would seem like more
British actors than Americans worked
their way through the ranks of theater
or at least classically trained at
places like Rada and central how would
you explain the drama tradition and
Britain to an outsider
caller New York right guys the theater
scene Harris is pretty consistent very
professional some really top-notch
training it's the same thing than UK but
the special thing about the UK is that
the theatres are also tied to
after-school activities so you can get
involved in theater for meeting young
and that's how I got involved was just a
youth group and then we ended up you
know connecting with different theaters
different performances and that's why
you really either get the bug where you
can't leave it be boys boys a good
experience do you see any difference and
say an actor who has a theatre
background and a big-budget movie set
versus someone who's just been doing TV
and film since the beginning you know I
thought it depends on the individual I
think that some people are talented to
the point where regardless of the format
they adjust and adapt and some people
just have it I guess it depends if
you've been doing TV for a long while
maybe there's some bad habits you pick
up you know you're not used to you know
transitioning onto stage it's a
different process also preparing for for
stage work so it just depends on the
individual to me but you know there is a
significant jump from film to TV venture
to stage is you know three different
formats and then I know one of the
places that you studied was at the
identity school for acting yeah what is
special about that place because there
seems to be a lot of the alumni popping
up in big huge blockbusters all over the
place right now it's incredible like
that was just basically a drama school
set up by my agent
Femi organs and he was in London and
found that not a lot of black people are
getting into mainstream drama schools
you know what were finding the you know
one per class inand that and that for
for him it wasn't enough he had been an
actor before and he was in like you know
EastEnders you know those you know
British TV shows and in on the leaflet
he was basically saying you know get
trained by actors who've been in you
know EastEnders
casualty and who's talking by himself
but fruit through that he set up a drama
school and me latisha riot Malachi Kirby
some of the British names that you know
now I've see on that one on the big
screen we went there and it was a hub of
creativity where you know with just a
lot of young people who had the same
dream who didn't laugh at each other's
dream and it was cool like I live it's
like some of the best days of my life I
really enjoyed it
you know got some so first we feast
recently did a deep dive into the
connection between anime and hip hop on
this new show that we have called go Chi
gang and I know that you're a huge fan
yep what do you think it is about anime
why do you think it's inspired such a
huge global following anime I think
because of its long-form format so it
lasts for ages you take a summer night
in our ruto for example you literally
watch a character grow up day by day and
then there are filler episodes that give
you kind of like clarity on the world
surrounding the leads of the several
different leads in and in the anime and
it's just the way it's the way they tell
stories a lot of the time when
characters are like standing in one
scene you're going into their
subconscious mind you know like for
example
I'm here like I'm doing well the chicken
wings are good but [ __ ] I don't know if
this next one's about to blow my [ __ ]
freaking brains to the sky right it's
like that and they do like a
subconscious thing we go back and forth
and that's cool I really like that it's
great way of storytelling this fun and I
guess it just touches - did they tap
into the imagination of individuals and
people just really really loved it there
was actually on YouTube an anime version
of Star Wars they had the X wings flying
in they animated exactly like what it
would be like in an anime TV show and it
actually it actually really really
worked like really really then I think
the x-wings
the spaceships the lightsaber fights all
that kind of stuff is anime esque
what would you recommend like if
somebody are just dipping their toes
under the anime pond and they were just
wanting to get started what do you think
are some titles to get them started I
would say attack on Titan I definitely
say Naruto
one punch man one punch one punch man
larry's people say I look like one punch
man I get that tweeted that I know yeah
you know lassithi on my little bit that
one look moist Erised in that source of
that okay what's going on the biggest
fan of his sauce taste is a bit fire
that horseradish yeah yeah no big fan of
that what that's the way still sitting
until you do not mean stick
all right time we have a recurring
segment on our show called explain that
Graham where we do a deep dive on our
guest Instagram pull interesting
pictures that need more context yeah so
we'll just put them up on their monitor
you tell us the bigger story does that
sound good yeah sounds great
rusty I have people at home if I've got
chicken wings at the corner of my mouth
he is way he's [ __ ] so this first one
okay someone said to me that it looked
like I was taking horse riding lessons
from Putin it is amazing okay the fit is
amazing child to daily paper a really
good fit I was training for Star Wars
Episode nine there's a big Calvary scene
that we we have specifically me and know
Naomi and this was one of the days that
it was just hot as hell I've been in the
gym and I thought you know what
shedding moms man all right up next we
have a Tokyo my best friend Asia I'm a
boy Stefon we were there for for a
little bit and we were just exploring P
big kids were all into anime you know
Gundam stuff but they have a big like
life-size condom in the middle of Tokyo
that would change like whoo that would
morph like in the evenings like this is
actually crazy I'm about to go again I'm
gonna do a whole bunch of stuff but this
was just us exploring the gaming
district that had like a lot of arcades
figures well that's nothing you just
looking around
why is not in Hill Carnival it's such a
big deal such a big deal you know what I
go in trouble for this [ __ ]
what I went to I went to not in whole
carnival and I caught wines like you
know you go not on who carnival we're
gonna catch wines like you wine on a
scale you know it's a dance and Ernest
that's what I'll do I'll Carnival this
is one of my many subjects and
we had a fantastic time take a picture
and I don't know I guess there was some
Disney fans who were like uptight and be
like oh so that's what Disney wouldn't
do a thing like that
I'm not shut up man catching wines at
carnival yeah baby I'm going on boom
yeah okay cool my subconscious just one
of this
I put an item off me mmm my spicy so I I
read that before you accepted the role
of Finn JJ Abrams he gave you a long
speech cautioning you about the
responsibilities that go with being a
part of a franchise that's as iconic as
Star Wars mm-hmm the morality that he
was speaking about the responsibility
for me like I found that nice because
you know this is someone who was just
kind of like keep it humble be yourself
enjoy this experience but make sure you
understand that
you know obviously a lot of people are
gonna be watching you make sure every
choice that you make is something that
you're okay with it's such an
interesting position to be in where it's
like oh here's a role that's just gonna
catapult you into a spot that nothing in
life really builds you for I'm not
nothing prepares you for it and a lot of
people who had opinions as into how it
was gonna go and I was all ears you know
but there's nothing like you going
through that yourself and then finding
out what works for you and what what
does it and then you get a letter right
there before every sentence my man's
left listen what's goin on minutes but
it gets me ten seasons in oh yeah
closing outside my mother's you know
you're right it's like a running back
yeah you're right I put a lot of miles
you're right I do
you know fresh from college you know I
mean yeah I get it I get it
and then you get a lot of credit for
being an ambassador to Star Wars and for
Star Wars and you're not afraid to mix
it up with fans or respond to feedback
on Twitter yeah
when has trying to out nerd the Nerds
backfired on you
never never never has I choose my
battles wisely and a lot of the times
online I'm I'm like so intrigued to hear
what the fans think to hear how they
feel and they're just disgust fingers as
nerds I think the the biggest one that I
did was when I said that Anakin
Skywalker is a stronger a much better
Jedi than he is and I think actually the
fans kind of galvanized behind you yeah
and I mean well you know whether were
sometimes we'll just like that's not
true but no you lion Anakin's Tucci Rey
will get pushed to the side we will all
get slammed to the wall and held there
so while he fights so like guess just
true
[Music]
my kneecaps are shaking a bit I can't
lie I'm doing well the chicken wings are
good again ha but that just means this
guy I feel like you are gonna have a
Nigerian woman walk out with pepper soup
right now yeah you got it is the season
10 finale what's going on so in addition
your ps4 and jo Malone London cents I
know that one thing you always travel
with one thing you always travel with is
books
is there a self-help book that you can
say actually changed your life for the
better I would say Devon Franklin's
produced by faithful was quite work
quite a good book I really enjoyed it
from someone in industry that then
speaks about you know faith growth
industry matters in a very very cool way
that was something that definitely was
motivating to me I thought this she has
been we've I've learned so many lessons
man like I've learned so many lessons
about myself I've made some changes I'm
just in a way you know I interact with
with people my friends who you know
within my family mom and dad had to take
care of their more so for 2020 I
actually want to see those lessons
exercise
[Music]
all right the bomb beyond insanity okay
why is this what we looking so red I
thought that the hot wing is looking
back at me that is
oh yes on that Nigerian heat scale we
starting them we in the gana God man
Sammy hey we're in a game now win the
game so I know that in the lead-up to
Star Wars you would do months of
lightsaber fight tiny woo to prepare for
the film mm-hmm do you remember the
first time you picked up a light saber
heavier than you thought it would be
lighter than you thought it would be
heavy it was a P heavy as hell but we
had a lot training they came in Taurus
our student might say but what's the
basic news and then we slide going I
hate getting faster stronger I really
really had a good time
well I don't know if you're aware of
this but on YouTube there is a whole
genre of amateur Jedi's though it seems
that very few of them actually have
taken to me when I'm glad fruit is
profit so what I want to do but he
ignores everything you're going to show
you some of the aspiring Jedi's that we
found on YouTube and I'm just wondering
if you have any snap takes to this okay
first up what do you think of this
spinning backfist
now if if the verse one of the Sabres on
set you would have finished you would
have been finished
if those Sabres caught you on set you
would have been knocked out so that
that's dangerous but that was good all
right up next how strong is the force
with this juggling Jedi does he have the
wing in his mouth
sit I'm impressed but during the video
all I saw was swirling flames is that
like a filter you guys have in a studio
because that classy [ __ ] definitely not
a personal problem definitely not a
personal problem oh my gosh this despise
was on the cloth and I wiped onto my
nose that's like something double [ __ ] I
did wear some watch the eyes are
definitely washed eyes
whoo all right there's anything like
this ever happens you on set here we
have a father-son yeah yep
he just called his son awesome is that -
oh yeah Adam driver actually caught me a
few times on my fingers and I genuinely
I got mad about it I was like this guy
needs to aim up man or don't aim at all
so we're going back and forth
I actually disarmed him and he's saved
by like flew and landed in the snow the
whole crew was like I was like that's
how I should have ended that's how it
should have ended all right one more for
you yep and it has nothing to do with
light sabers per se yeah kid I said you
guys do the heat and Lucifer dwelling in
my mouth
here's a guy farting the tune of the
Imperial March just curious if you cool
your mouth I'm confused when I dropped
the load like you know we freestyling so
I don't know what's going on down there
[Music]
[Music]
I mean after that move on to walk Ian's
fire I don't I don't know why I think
you know playing with you in my hand
it's gonna change was like our gonna
find some spot on a you know I mean yeah
[Music]
that boom right there Oh Carl I
pretended it went to my spirit bro I
felt it in my head in fact we were
talking I'd understand a word you were
saying well you know what you executed
the the segment flawlessly yeah thank
you so it's a real pro later than real
tomorrow thank you thank you so much
shouts I see disarray she's a she's a
reason for the season she handled it
like a pro hey I love that Easter
episode I just feel like she handled it
very very well you're doing great too
job I am I am I feel okay I'm welcome
good our best friends day week we cool
sorry
I heard you joke that your father
responded to you being cast in Star Wars
by saying what is Star Wars yeah is
there a role or accomplishment from your
career so far that you think has
resonated especially well with your
parents with my dad I did a Nigerian
movie called half of the Yellow Sun with
to tell Gia four tiny new and I was back
home in Nigeria shoo-in and Pacific Rim
for a mom and dad
they thought Pacific Rim was banned
install was sad the end of the screen in
matters like you know what you know I
can understand this Pacific Rim better
than these Star Wars that was they'll be
running I don't understand a word I
don't know that's not what's going on
what this one right here I love it
do you have a special spot in your heart
for the fans who approached you because
they recognize you from Law & Order or
24 yeah yes it's funny you say Lauren
Odom because in law nor does one of my
best performances yet in which I play a
guest criminal as you do and then
there's other people that would be like
yo I loves your stock shoot for her
modeling pitches a mic we took them out
here I forgot about those because I I've
done a bunch of stock shoot Oh
before I became yeah you're like
director like the college brochure thing
yeah I am I used to be signed to like
spotlight all these free audition sites
and all that stuff and they always used
to have these opportunities there and
one of them was paying 50 pounds
obviously those stocks shoot photos will
now go online and colleges all over the
world would not buy it I'm proud to
announce that I've just been accepted
into college in Dallas don't know the
name of college but I'm in the stairwell
well look how far you've come
I know john-boy and did i flick did i
flinch no I got this my saw is plenty of
crisp
[Music]
alright John this is the last dab we
call it the last DAF because it's
tradition around here to put a little
extra on the last one how you shaking it
like that MA you don't have to if you
don't want to don't say that all right I
pray to you Issa Rae whoa
guide me
cheers Cheers
[Music]
[Music]
alright John boyega here we are
rummy magic man at the end wanna check
the end of the season yeah the end of
the year and before the acting thing
Takaki understand that he had a dream of
being a newspaper cartoonist yeah we
would be honored if you gave us a quick
doodle that we can hang forever and the
hot ones museum of curiosity hell yeah
love you
[Music]
[Music]
this will take a village we got time we
got time there we go
inspired by the wings of death and what
a masterpiece it is help me donate two
dollars and fifty cents for all the
victims of hot ones please I need you
and look at you John boyega chicken
wings up ten chicken wings down
your moves and no war - shut it down
season 10 It's A Wrap appreciator and
now I have to do is roll out the red
carpet for you my friend thank you this
camera this camera this camera
some people know what you have going on
in your life thank you so you know
currently I've just wrapped up on Steve
McQueen's small axe and that's gonna
come out 2020 I've just signed onto
Netflix feature they cloned Tyrone and
wouldn't be doing an another action
movie called rebel Ridge I forgot about
the indie that have coming out about the
turn of a stormtrooper to a resistance
fighter it's a small little film please
support Star Wars the rise of Skywalker
is small budget only on 20 screens would
love for you to be there please make
your kid's dream come true yeah no not I
don't have control over the rest of my
body I'm there like this but look at
this
no water no mill we were in a stalemate
for a week hey what's going on hot ones
fans this is Sean Evans checking in to
say thank you so much for watching
today's video
and have a very exciting announcement
for our hot ones Hot Sauce Box
subscribers we have gone completely
bizarro world in the December box take a
look at what I mean we have taken pepper
X from the last dab and we have put it
in the classic the classic but with a
kick we have taken the chile de árbol
from the classic put it in the last dab
mild it out a little bit and then we've
taken red jalapeno and put it in los
caliente slows calientes look at it it's
red I don't know if we'll ever do this
again
but it will be in the December box for
our hot ones Hot Sauce Box subscribers
if you're not a subscriber and you want
to get your hands on the
our OPAC heat nice calm heat nice calm
to subscribe thank you very much and
happy Holidays to you and yours from us
here at hot ones bang bang
[Music]